Americans feelings about foreign policy
aren't very impassioned especially when
a draft is not the issue magazine and
author of the book radicals for
capitalism a history of the modern
American libertarian movement the
perception of being anti-war as a as a
strictly left progressive thing I think
is a holdover from the Vietnam War when
all sorts of young people who had a
counterculture hippie ferment amongst
them outside the issues of foreign
policy tended to be the loudest anti-war
voices because they were the bodies that
were at risk of being sent by force over
to fight the war but it didn't used to
be that way from the late 1890s when the
US was first beginning its world
straddling Empire role during the war
with Spain and our subjugation of the
Philippines there was a mass
anti-imperialist league of middle-class
businessmen some wealthy businessmen who
who had this 19th century and hopefully
perhaps later 21st century vision of a
limited constitutional republic the
notion that American wealth and American
treasure and American lives should not
be expended on these futile missions of
reshaping the world has a respectably
middle-class respectably Republican
respectably
you know bourgeois pedigree in the 30s
anti-war activism associated with things
like the America first community was a
super respectable Midwestern businessman
the kind
it was you know the Chicago Tribune was
the major you know anti intervention
newspaper and all of these stout burgers
who ran their own you know chemical
companies and Meatpacking companies
these were the people who who sort of
understood viscerally especially with
the memory of World War one vivid what
war meant it just meant hundreds and
thousands of American kids being sent
from their jobs from their farms from
their families and being killed it could
easily be embraced as a traditional
family value because one thing that war
successfully do especially to any family
whose members get involved in that those
Wars is disrupt disrupt families take
you know fathers from their children
husbands from their wives sons from
their parents
libertarians unfortunately in modern
American history have always been too
small a political constituency to
actually shape the course of political
events but in intellectual history terms
it was issues of war in foreign policy
that created a distinct libertarian
movement to begin with in the immediate
Roosevelt and post Roosevelt era there
was this inchoate group of people
against the New Deal for strictly
limited constitutional government for
relatively unrestricted free market some
of them call themselves libertarians
some of them called themselves
conservatives they didn't necessarily
see that much of a distinction between
themselves and that distinction arose
throughout the 50s and was really made
remarkably clear by conservative
Godfather William Buckley the founder of
National Review the most influential
conservative magazine of the post-war
era which began in 1955 Buckley and
other conservatives took the view which
is anathema to most libertarians that
the threat of Soviet Communism was so
severe that for the duration of the Cold
War we needed to forget about this whole
notion of constitutionally limited
government we had to give the government
all the power it needed to spy and
subversives to spend money on weapons
systems to finance education at high
levels because the commies managed to
send a little beeping ball up into space
you know all of these considerations
were thought more important than
domestic Liberty
early libertarians like Leonard read of
the foundation for economic education or
the libertarian economist Murray
Rothbard was still very influential
today in the Ron Paul movement they
focused on liberty above all and liberty
for the American people above all that
it was not the mission of the American
government to fight wars forever with
the promise of somehow liberating the
world that that was considered a foolish
and impossible mission and I think
history has largely proven them right
it's clear that one of the main reasons
that the Vietnam War created such mass
social ferment was amongst the people
who saw the potential for themselves to
be drafted and sent away to fight and
die in it and their families a volunteer
military which a great libertarian
victory largely inspired by Milton
Friedman has had the side effect of
diminishing people's emotions about
foreign policy
it is usually a salutary instinct on the
part of American people that they're not
that violently concerned with what's
going on in the rest of the world
they're the unfortunate aspect of that
is that politicians are generally able
to get away with doing whatever they
want when it comes to foreign policy
even if the people ostensibly object to
it the anti-war movement in America has
been unfortunately neutered since the
Ascension of Barack Obama to the
presidency what fooled some anti-war
people of libertarian bent in the Bush
era as being an actual and encouraging
representation of a real mass popular
movement against the war one that didn't
only express itself in poll numbers but
in actual people willing to get out in
the streets willing to put public
political pressure on politicians proved
to be unfortunately just one more reflex
of the American progressives left
anger with George Bush in the Republican
Party partisan pride and an inability to
admit a mistake now locks both parties
into supporting these wars it's wars
that george w bush started so the
republicans are implicated its wars that
barack obama is now having to manage
it's hard to believe that anything
you know declaring that we're invading
France is going to upset his base Obama
made what's proven to be a savvy
political calculation that it didn't
matter if he tried to appease or make
happy the anti-war vote out there that
the anti-war vote for various other
reasons is to locked in to being
supporters of the Democratic Party while
I would say to the Democrats of the
world you you can be more dedicated to
your principles than to your politicians
I would say that the Republicans you
know george w bush is and should be
considered part of the republican
party's past everything about his
policies from war to spending or things
that the current republican party needs
to run away from to the extent that the
republican party the Tea Party movement
takes the notion of limited responsible
affordable constitutional government at
all seriously they have to look at
foreign policy and war to be
intellectually consistent and
politically intelligent that does not
mean that I expect that intellectual
consistency or political intelligence in
the immediate term but I'm encouraged by
the existence of on pala types and by
what I expected the a rising number of
Republican primary challengers and House
and Senate races who hopefully will
begin changing the median
Republican opinion about foreign policy
[Music]
[Applause]